YEN-JIE LEE: I try to include
a questionnaire during
the semester, in--
I think, it's actually in
the middle of the semester--
along with the problem set.
So the reason is the following.
I would like to know
how my class is doing.
Because every year, the
composition of the students
is actually different.
Every semester is, actually,
they are different.
And also students may have
different background knowledge
semester by semester.
So doing this kind
of questionnaire
will help me to
understand where we are
and whether we are doing
great, or are we actually
moving too fast or too slow?
Are we not giving enough help
or giving too much homework?
And is everybody keeping
up with the content
which we cover
during the lecture?
And this kind of feedback
is actually, particularly
useful during the semester.
Because during the
semester, I still
have the chance to
adjust the speed,
to adjust the
content, which will
be suitable for the
composition of the students
I get in the class
this semester.
So that is actually why I try
to ask them to provide feedback
on first, the speed
of the course.
Second, how helpful is the
lecture, and the instructor,
and also the
recitation sections?
And finally, how is
actually the problem
sets and the other
materials actually
help you with the learning?
Do we need more for example
... do we need more solved
examples?
Do we need more
ways to communicate
between the instructors
and the students,
such that the students can
get the help they need--
not only through the
lecture, but also
through the Piazza program which
we have during this semester.
And also by emails,
and the recitations,
and the office hour, with
the instructors and the TAs.
So with that kind
of survey, we will
be able to get the feedback
during the semester.
And we can actually
adjust to actually fit
the need of the class.